San Pietro small island off the coast of
Sardinia since the time of Caesar men
have fished these fertile Mediterranean
waters their most prized catch the
mighty bluefin tuna a species revered as
food and as a worthy opponent
Capernaum Bosch a tuna is a very strong
fish be generous and the one that breaks
the Nets that's the tuna I really love
there's some of the strongest beasts on
earth equipped with oxygen rich muscle
tissue that allows them to stay warm and
agile even when hunting in frigid 40
degree waters tunas swim with astounding
power and stamina even reaching speeds
of 60 miles an hour so strong they can
easily travel across the Atlantic Ocean
in weeks huge and shimmering bluefin
tuna fend off predators by schooling
underwater deftly corralling and killing
prey tuna have a limitless capacity to
grow larger and larger record tuna have
stretched as long as 15 feet weighing
nearly 1,500 pounds but no matter how
big they get their bulk never slows them
down bluefin tuna swim faster than it's
legal to drive on most freeways these
are very large very fast growing fish
and when a fish is as large as they're
very little in the ocean can threaten
them
no man can hand fish bluefin alone it
takes a tuna catching company called a
tanara the head of the fishermen is the
rice arabic for leader more than anyone
he bears the burden of their feast or
famine rice the vessel - bap the rice is
the expert he has to be able to feel and
practically be able to talk to the tuna
each spring tanara fisherman called Tona
wrote a drop woven nets into the sea
creating an elaborate maze stretching
nearly a mile as tuna migrate to the
northwest
they swim into a single net stretching
half a mile to the shore called the tail
the tail diverts the tuna into the trap
once inside the fish Corral into a
series of chambers ultimately leading to
the final net nicknamed the chamber of
death the rice decides when the nets are
full watching and checking them in
regular John's from shore on his go the
collective must be ready for one of the
most back-breaking hand fishing
practices on earth May time for the
harvest the men begin pulling the net
dragging their boats inward forcing the
fish four towards the chamber of death
as the net closed in what starts as an
almost mile-long tuna Traub ends up as a
single net more than twice the size of a
swimming pool
not just the net weighs several tons you
have to raise it with your hands you
need a lot of strength to avoid net
ripping chaos timing is everything
Oakland will spend carry fish on the
ostrich Kennedy we can lose fish when we
attempt to close them in the chamber of
death
chef's guys Fonda the Nets can collapse
and this makes the job even harder
at last it's time for the matanza
Italian for slaughter a massive fish
flip at the surface if the men dropped
any part of the net the tuna could
escape one by one using hooks the toner
rotate jump into the water and wrestle
the behemoths on board modern commercial
boats will ion winches here they used
powerful arms proud to keep an ancient
tradition alive
the grueling work takes hours the men
are exhausted yet no one quits
at last after months of preparing
planning and plotting the matanza the 42
men to Nara team hoists up the final
tuna surveying the mammoth catch mission
accomplished